[Intro Music]
NF: OK Toxic Avengers, accumulate!
I'd like to call this
meeting to order.
NF: First, I would like to
thank Admiral Murica for
his tireless work to remove all
the asbestos from the cafeteria.
NF: Job well done, soldier.
NF: However, Bulk.
NF: I hear you caused
substantial damage on
our last field mission.
Bulk: Bulk just trying
to save peoples from
killer robot peoples.
NF: [with outrage] That doesn't
explain the devouring of every
bagel and donut
shop in Brooklyn!
Bulk: [groaning] Bulk sorry.
NF: [with authority] Go fix it!
Bulk: Bulk just really
like donuts and bagels...
[crowd laughter]
Leadman: I have arrived.
The meeting can start now.
Black meadow: The meeting
started five minutes ago.
As scheduled.
Leadman: Hey!
Relax Black Meadow.
Let Leadman come
sit next to you.
You'll feel better
about this in no time.
Nick Fiery: Yeah,
about that Leadman.
We're going to have to
do something about that.
Lead is toxic to the humans
you are [-cough-] saving.
Leadman: What?
No way, eye patch!
This is my lead suit.
Leadman: The ladies dig it!
Black meadow: [Gags].
Leadman: Hey!
It protects me!
I don't have to worry about
X-rays or nuclear radiation.
How can it hurt those humans?
Nick Fiery: [with
outrage] I'm Sorry.
I didn't create the
laws of the universe.
Nick Fiery: You need to work
with Professor Plumbum here to
recreate the newer, safer
version of yourself.
Further instructions
are on your ship.
Leadman: [with defiance] Hey,
I'll show this Professor Plumbum
that I am fine
just the way I am.
Leadman ain't
going to change.
No sir.
Envelope: This message will
self-destruct in 10 seconds.
LM: I don't want to go
to some museum to
find a flower painting.
Are you kidding me?
I'm a superhero!
Flowers?
Ugh.
[self-destruct noise]
Leadman: Hah! - I wasn't
even singed by that.
Go lead powers!
LM: [obnoxiously] Those
flowers sure are pretty.
PP: Yes, there are 82 of them.
All are deadly.
LM: They're flowers!
PP: They are made of lead.
LM: [Yawns] Oh yeah-I hear
there's a "lead problem"?
I'm Leadman.
PP: I'm Professor
Plumbum...
LM: [with suspicion]
Professor Plumbum?
In the library?
With a lead pipe?!
PP: [annoyed] That
was Professor Plum,
I am Professor Plumbum.
Though lead pipes are
involved in lead poisoning.
LM: Uh...
I'm confused.
Poisoning?
Lead?
No, No, No...
I'm the medicine
you need, baby.
PP: [With sarcasm] That's not
surprising that you're confused.
Look Leadman,
this is serious.
For both of us.
We have to recreate you.
You cannot continue to
contact the humans in
your current condition.
LM: [excited] What do you mean?
Look at this suit.
Isn't it amazing??
You can't mess with perfection.
PP: [Sigh] Let's start
at the beginning.
[time travel sound]
Uh, okay, where are we now?
PP: We are on the
Periodic Table of Elements.
LM: I thought I was supposed
to have the superpowers.
PP: [Ignores LM] Lead
is element number 82,
with the symbol Pb.
PP: It's a soft silver bluish
metal that quickly turns to
a black color when
exposed to air.
PP: Lead is a very useful
metal because-
LM: [Interrupting, with
excitement] Number one!
It has a low
melting point.
PP: Melting point is the
temperature at which
a solid melts to a liquid.
LM: Lead can be melted into
a liquid at much lower
temperatures than other metals.
LM: And then made
into the desired shape.
So I better knock it
off with the fire suit.
LM: [with enthusiasm]
Number two!
It is malleable -
PP: That is, easy to form
into different shapes.
LM: [grunts] I can be
flat like aluminum foil.
LM: [grunts] I can be long
and thin like a pipe.
LM: [grunts] Or I can
be round like a ball.
Any shape really.
LM: [With enthusiasm]
Number three!
Lead is also very stable
over time and resists corrosion-
PP: [interrupting] The
gradual wearing away by
reacting with other
chemicals it's exposed to.
[Sound of chemicals pouring
on Leadman, who is un-phased]
LM: [Action-hero music]
I am Leadman!
Lead is great!
PP: These properties have
made lead very useful to
mankind throughout history.
PP: To its detriment,
as we'll see in a bit.
[Vanishing sound:
LM and PP vanish]
PP: Elemental lead-lead
just by itself-is
extremely rare in nature.
Lead compounds-mixtures of
lead and other elements-are
found in the Earth's crust-the
part that we can walk on-and
are still rare.
LM: [with excitement] Oh
yeah, I'm a rare bird.
So, why is it a problem to
humans if it's so rare, like me?
PP: Lead is one of the
easiest metals to separate from
other metals in compounds
mined out of the Earth's crust.
Archeological research
has identified lead mines
dating back to
6000 years ago.
PP: Even before these
mines, lead compounds were
used by ancient peoples.
[Vanishing sound:
LM and PP vanish]
PP: Lead sulfate-a black
compound-was used as
eyeliner in the Stone Age.
PP: Lead oxide-yellow and
red in color-was used to
glaze pottery in 5000 B.C.
PP: And pure lead figurines
have been excavated from
Egyptian ruins dating
to 4000 B.C., along with
weights, vessels,
and other metal work.
PP: Lead coins have been
found dating to 3500 B.C. from
both Assyria and China.
[Vanishing sound:
LM and PP vanish]
PP: Romans took lead
use to new depths.
PP: With the manpower to
extract pure lead from mines-
and great engineering-the Romans
used lead pipes in their
aqueducts-water bridges-to
deliver waters to the cities.
PP: Remember lead's
chemical symbol?
It's Pb.
The Latin word for lead was
plumbum, and the modern word
plumber comes from this word.
LM: [with confidence] Well,
that really means you're...
Lead Woman.
Don't fill yourself
with hate for lead.
You need to be more
[brief pause] malleable.
PP: Lead is sometimes
called the Roman metal.
They used lead in all
facets of their lives,
PP: From curse tablets,
sheets in Bath to lead
compounds in their make-up
and paint products as well
LM: [with enthusiasm] See!
The Roman Empire glorified
lead-and nothing bad
ever happened to them!
You can't have
too much lead.
PP: [ignoring LM] In
addition to the pipes,
most households had pots and
drinking vessels made from lead.
[Teleportation sounds]
PP: Lead and its compounds
have a sweet taste.
The Romans used lead
acetate as a food seasoning
PP: and as a wine preservative.
PP: They also concentrated
grape juice into syrup by
boiling it in lead pots.
The acid from the juice
would have caused lead to
leech into the syrup.
LM: [with enthusiasm] So
the humans liked lead,
it was easy to work with,
they used it everywhere.
How cool is that!
PP: One small problem:
Lead and its compounds are
toxic to humans-and
other animals-on Earth.
LM: hmm-Toxic?
What does that mean?
PP: Toxic means poisonous-a
substance causing or capable of
causing death or illness
if taken into the body.
PP: Well, crying isn't going to
help your toxic little problem!
LM: [defiantly] Fine!
How does it get in?
[Teleportation sounds]
PP: There are 3 ways things
can be taken in, or absorbed,
by the human body.
PP: Number one: Through their
skin when they touch things.
PP: Number two: Through
their stomachs and
intestines when they eat.
PP: and Number three: Through
their lungs when they breathe.
LM: Well-I thought those
things protected the humans,
like my lead suit protects me?
PP: That's true for many things.
But each of these is
made up of living cells.
These cells absorb things from
the environment
and the bloodstream.
The lung and intestinal cells
will also absorb the lead.
LM: What about the skin?
Isn't that stuff dead?
PP: The skin cells are truly
more protective cells, and
in the case of lead,
do NOT absorb much lead.
Just touching a lead object is
not going to poison the human.
LM: What about eating
it-that sounds bad.
PP: Once eaten, 20 to 50%
of the lead eaten will be
absorbed into the
bloodstream of the human.
Breathing it is worse - Of the
lead breathed in from the air,
nearly 100% of the lead is
absorbed into the bloodstream.
LM: [with curiosity] Whoa,
what does that mean?
PP: Alright-if there were
10 grams of lead in the
room with you and you ate it.
You would absorb 2 to 5 grams of
the lead into your bloodstream.
PP: If you breathed it
in-nearly all 10 grams of
the lead would be absorbed
into your bloodstream.
PP: The dose was the same
(10 grams), but the amount in
the body is different
because of how it was taken in.
PP: [with concern]
Another important point:
Children absorb
MORE than adults.
LM: So now it's in their
blood-how does it poison them?
PP: Once in the
bloodstream, the lead can
travel to all
parts of the body.
It has different effects
depending upon which
organ of the body
it is affecting.
PP: The primary target
is the nervous system.
PP: When lead is absorbed
by the cells of the brain,
it causes permanent
damage, including: decreased
intelligence [clears throat],
memory loss, paralysis, and
decreased social skills [stares
at Leadman meaningfully].
LM: Hey!
We're talking about humans here.
Lead doesn't affect my species.
But why does it target
the human brain?
PP: The brain is
sensitive to lead-
a tiny amount
causes big problems.
Other cells can handle the
lead a little bit better.
LM: Give me the rest of
it-what else does it do?
PP: In the guts-lead
poisoning causes cramping,
pain, and constipation.
PP: In the blood itself,
there are low levels of
healthy red blood cells-the
ones that transport oxygen to
all the cells of the body.
Poisoned humans also show
reduced appetite and feel tired.
PP: [sad voice] It damages
cells everywhere, in the
lungs, the kidneys, and
the reproductive system.
LM: [sad voice] How much
does it take to poison a human?
PP: [sad voice] There is
no safe dosage of lead.
A high dose all at once
results in acute lead poisoning,
with symptoms affecting
the neurological and
digestive systems the most.
PP: [sad voice] Long-term
exposure to lower doses,
results in chronic
lead poisoning.
PP: [sad voice] The cells
are being damaged all over,
but at a slower rate, so the
human doesn't appear to be
poisoned because it
happens over a long time.
PP: Even the Romans knew
about acute lead poisoning from
observing their miners,
painters, and metal workers
coming down with the
disease-didn't know about
the chronic
poisoning, though.
LM: So, the Romans
stopped using it.
Right?
Right?!?
PP: [giggling] Do
you always follow
the speed limit in
your spaceship??
Knowing about the dangers
and not engaging in them
are two different things.
[Teleportation sounds]
LM: [in the dark]
And where are we now?
PP: The dark
ages of course.
PP: Lead mining and use
were much lower during
this time period up
until the 19th century.
One notable exception was
the mechanical moveable
type printing press.
PP: Gutenberg combined several
existing technologies to create
this press that used
lead-based printing blocks.
PP: Lead was melted with tin
and antimony and poured into
molds to form the
printing blocks.
PP: Lead was also used to make
bullets and weights for fishing;
remember, lead can be
melted over a regular
wood fire, then melded
into the desired shape.
LM: Those workers
don't look so good.
LM: I thought lead wasn't
absorbed well through the skin?
PP: That' true, the danger
comes from breathing the dust
coming off the items as they
are handled or heated, and
eating small amounts
from your hands and lips if
they are not washed off
after working with the metal.
LM: So humans are sickened by
me because of small amounts of
lead dusts coming off of me?
That can't be true!
I use a dandruff
reducing shampoo!
PP: Yes-the lead dust
coming off of you is
a possibility for the
sickness that could happen.
That's why we have
to recreate you.
[Teleportation sounds]
LM: Where are we now?
PP: Focus!
We're in the 1800s.
LM: Ah, so WHEN
are we now...
thought I was the superhero.
Hey-I want one of these
time buttons you have here.
PP: [annoyed] Focus!
Focus!
The industrial revolution
brought with it mining at
levels never seen before.
PP: Lead was easily
accessed and cheap, with
many industrial uses.
PP: Just as in Roman
times, people used it for
pipes or to connect
copper pipes together.
PP: As in Roman times, usually
as long as the water is flowing,
very little lead from the
pipes gets into the water.
[Teleportation sounds]
PP: One of the largest problems
of modern times came with
the use of lead carbonate,
which looks like this: (PbCO3)
[Music]
PP: It was used to produce
bright white color in
indoor house paints.
PP: Just as artists before had
prized lead carbonate
for the same quality.
[Teleportation sounds]
PP: Lead-based paint was
used to paint virtually
all indoor spaces
beginning in the 1800s
PP: until the 1950s
PP: before completely
phasing out by about
1977 in the United States.
PP: This paint is
toxic when eaten.
LM: [giggling]
Wait-who's eating paint?
PP: Remember how the
Romans used lead acetate
as seasoning on their food?
Lead tastes sweet to humans.
[Teleportation sound]
PP: Young children may find
paint chips on the floor,
eat them and then look for more.
People of all ages may
possibly breathe in
the paint dust as well.
LM: [with concern]
wait, wait! -hold it!
So-now the humans are surrounded
by lead in their houses?
PP: In a way-but-it gets worse.
LM: They're surrounded
by it, drink it, and eat it.
How does it get worse?
PP: Henry Ford changed the
world with the creation of
the first moving assembly
line car, the Model-T.
PP: This made cars affordable
to working families,
not just the very rich.
The other car companies
quickly moved to copy the
assembly line and make money
selling cars to everyone.
PP: Competitor's
developed fancier cars,
but their engines had problems.
PP: Engineers found adding
a lead compound,
Tetraethyl lead (TEL),
fixed the engine's problems.
LM: Ok-but correct me if
I'm wrong-I don't think
people on this
planet eat cars.
PP: Tetraethyl lead is
also known as TEL-and these
TEL additives are extremely
toxic to produce and
car exhausts emitted
the lead product
directly into the ATMOSPHERE.
PP: Remember, the body absorbs
up to 100% of the lead that is
breathed in, so inhaling a
low dose of lead will cause
more problems than eating
the same dose of lead.
PP: It then causes all
those health problems
we talked about earlier.
LM: Well-this is not looking
good for the humans at all.
PP: Calm down.
There is good news.
The toxic effects were
recognized, and legislation
was passed to phase out
TEL additives starting in
1973 and ending in
1986 in the U.S.
PP: All leaded gas
additives were banned in
the US by the end of 1995.
Most countries today ban
leaded gas for automobiles.
PP: The levels of lead in the
human bloodstream dropped by
78% from 1978 to 1991 after
leaded gas was phased out.
LM: What about all those
"lead" pencils humans use?
What's up with that?
PP: [giggling] So-called lead
pencils actually use graphite,
a form of carbon that
is non-toxic to humans.
It has its name because
originally they thought
graphite was a form of lead.
LM: Oh.
Bummer.
I told this girl one time
that I made the pencil.
I got to make a call...
LM: So where does that
leave the humans today?
PP: Lead paint may be
found in buildings built
before 1978, but it is safe if
it is not peeling or powdery.
PP: Similarly, some houses
contain lead pipes.
PP: Leaded fuel is banned
in most countries,
and there is reduced lead
pollution in the air.
PP: Lead is still used for
many industrial processes and
products, and lead mining and
other industries continue to
expose workers and
communities to airborne lead.
PP: The 2 main uses today are
lead-based car batteries, and
X-ray and radiation protection.
PP: Other uses include
bullets and other ammunition,
use in glass and
ceramics, metal molds,
sheet lead (used in buildings,
roofs, to surround cables)
PP: and sometimes
it gets included in
jewelry, paint on
toys, cars, houses, etc.,
homeopathic medicine,
fishing equipment, candy
(remember the sweet taste?),
and metal decorations.
PP: So what did
we learn today?
LM: The very qualities
that make lead so useful to
humans also make
it extremely deadly.
PP [surprised]: Exactly.
Acute lead poisoning
by mining, painting,
plumbing, and using
the printing press,
was known in ancient times.
PP: The effects of chronic
lead poisoning by the use of
lead pipes, vessels,
paint, and other lead
compounds over a lifetime was
only described in recent times.
LM: Researchers continue to
study the levels of lead and to
support legislation to protect humans and the planet Earth.
PP: With some simple
precautions, humans can limit
their exposure to lead
in their daily lives.
LM: [excited] So, humans!
Protect yourselves from lead!
LM: #1-Don't play by old paint- you could eat it or inhale it.
LM: Don't let young children
touch or play with it either.
Also-don't play in
the dirt that may be
contaminated with old paint.
LM: And it's gross.
LM: It's GROSS.
Stop it.
PP: #2-Flush old pipes with
COLD water for 30 seconds if
the water is being used
for drinking or eating.
This allows any lead that may
have come off the pipes into
the water to flow out of
the pipe and into the drain.
Water that is flowing
through the pipes-not
sitting in them-is
very unlikely to be
contaminated with lead.
LM: #3-Use caution when buying
kid jewelry or toys or even
candy manufactured in
countries that do not have
strict laws on
the use of lead.
Look for lead-free
or non-toxic labels.
Different countries
have different laws
on lead and its use.
PP: #4-Thoroughly wash
your hands after handling
any lead solids-after
science class, hunting,
fishing, painting,
or handling pipes.
LM: #5-Recycle car batteries!
Limit the amount of lead that
gets into your local ecosystem.
LM: And #6-[embarrassed] Don't
go to my apartment right now.
I-I have a lot of cleaning
to do apparently.
I've learned a lot today.
D-Don't-don't-don't come by.
We're going to move the
party to next weekend-ladies.
PP: [giggling]
Anything else?
LM: Yeah-humans-uh wash your
hands before eating or drinking!
Leave your shoes
at the front door.
Um-don't wear a lead
suit all the time-
LM: It's okay for your dentist
to put one on for X-rays-the
lead in those aprons is
completely contained and
can't leak out.
PP: Knowledge is power-in
this case, protective power.
PP: Leadman?
PP: [annoyed]-Leadman?!?
LM: Yeah-no-uh-That's
Uranium-Plutonium
Fusion Man now.
LM: Thank you.
NF: This has been a presentation of the U.S. National Library of
Medicine Division of Specialized
Information Services.
Visit the Environmental
Health Student Portal for
more information on lead.
NF: [with authority]
Dismissed, soldier!